[Music]
stephen from lexington is up hey steven
welcome to the show
hey good afternoon how are y'all doing
absolutely good how are you
i'm doing well good how can we help
so i had a i've got a question my so my
wife hit me up the other day and
informed me she has 30 000 credit card
debt
i didn't know she had
we've been married for about 20 years
we've got a 20 year old and a 16 year
old
and
so she's done this to me once before she
wrecked up 25 000 in credit card debt
and i didn't really watch your show then
so i kind of
blew my top and split up our accounts
and took all the credit card debt myself
and got it paid back off
and i really thought if she got him in
the credit card they would you know
she wouldn't get a horrible limit she
wouldn't get a big limit this time
because it wouldn't be bumping both our
names anyway
yeah and it looks like i was wrong
so so now so now she's informed me that
she wants to her 0 on her credit card
here expiring
and she wants to take out a home loan
against her house that's paid off
no
no you don't want to take a lean against
your house no no that's that's a that's
a hard no okay so steven where you guys
are at
just in marriage
would you consider yourselves on the
same page with money are you guys still
living pretty separate lives
we're completely the opposite money-wise
i mean i'm i'm i'm more of a cash cash
only person i mean i i know y'all don't
y'all don't agree with it but i still
have a credit card but i don't use it
so uh
my debit card stephen um she's not on
the phone so i'm just going to address
you is that cool
that's fine um
so
she did something she violated your
trust right the first time around
violated your trust was deceitful we
call that financial infidelity here i
cheated on you with money she lied to
you and
another way to look at that is she acted
like a child right she's acting childish
i want it now i'm going to do whatever i
have to do to get it now
and you responded like a child
you threw a temper tantrum
you split everything up you yelled and
you kicked and screamed and you took
your ball and i'm going home and i'll
just do it myself
and now you found yourself right back in
the same spot
and so with this
situation neat this isn't a math problem
i mean it's clear it's a math problem
like rachel said absolutely
don't put your house up on the block to
clear up this mess
right you're gonna have to have some
some directed behavior change inside
your house
but brother you aren't just not on the
same page when it comes to your marriage
you're not on the same page with much
anything would be my guess and y'all
been probably great roommates and good
buddies um
but this is a wake up wake is that fair
pretty much right okay that's pretty
much that's right so there's a place
where she is violating your marriage
covenant she's lying to you there's also
a place where
she can't talk to you
because maybe you blow your top maybe
you get pissed off and run around and
then just solve the problems
and so this
can become either the thing that breaks
breaks your marriage up and you say i'm
done with you you don't tell me the
truth i'm out of here or this can be the
moment that you stop the music you throw
all the lights on in the disco and you
look at her in the eye and say we've got
to heal us
and that's going to start with us
getting honest about where we are fixing
our marriage and then getting serious
about money because steven you know when
we hear
these kinds of numbers or situations
for us we're like okay there's a money
problem obviously and there's a tactical
way to go about that the zero percent do
you take it in my house and all that
but really what we're hearing though is
underneath the surface that there are
more marriage issues than even financial
issues and when you guys can get the
marriage issues solved out of that comes
healthier habits with money that you
guys think can work as a team because
right now you're not working as a team
with your money and just like john said
probably a lot of other areas in life so
i would really it's a symptom this
credit card debt is a symptom of things
going on in the marriage so i would
encourage you guys get some help get
therapy get counseling and start working
on your marriage and then your money
becomes more of a team